welcome to the honest trailer commentary
for triple I'm Spencer Gilbert that's
dead ruin everything about my father
dead well what about you yeah yes mid
vin diesel noise today we're going to
talk about our thought process behind
the trailers show you some deleted
scenes if you stick around to the end
you will see a teaser for next week
sounds trailer and we forgot to print em
out again but I will scroll through some
of the top comments and questions and
will maybe respond to that yeah yeah if
you're lucky but first and foremost we
got to talk about the pinnacle of early
2000s ridiculous extreme sports spy
filmmaking and discuss the xxx franchise
yeah if I ever have kids or grandkids on
my knees and say Pappy what what were
the what were the 2000s like I will just
sit them down and show them what they
were like per se is like what did what
do people aspire to be yes what was the
what was the dream of every 60 year old
and - in the year 2000 if for our
grandparents it was to have like the
suit with the most fabric yeah or the
longest car the best Fedora best Fedora
largest rarest feather then for us it
was to be the most muscled mountain Dew
can of a human being
world's best extreme athlete spy sports
you do a McTwist into a woman and then
save the world
that's the xxx franchise promise yeah
one that they I think they went back on
I guess we can talk about now I the one
that I think they they violated in in
xxx - State of the Union yeah I think
that they moved away from what made it
great unique yeah yeah will you talk
about that later I I do think that these
are dumb fun in the way that I think the
fasten Furious movies are dumb fun yeah
I'm a sucker for extreme sports you know
I was as Avril Lavigne called it a
skater boy I'm a sucker for anyone doing
tricks off of something and this is just
fun these are slightly more self-aware
not completely software because Vin
Diesel is still intimately involved
and I'm convinced that he is a very
talented human being who lacks any
self-awareness whatsoever that's not
necessarily a negative thing but
sometimes it is but these are slightly
more self-aware than the Fast and the
Furious movies and that you do get the
feeling the last few Fast & Furious
movies after let's say Fast Five yeah
I've not really gotten the idea that
they were quote-unquote in on the joke
sure I'm thinking so much in or out on
the joke I think it's like is Vin
enjoying himself or not and I don't
think he's enjoying himself so much on
the latest fast movies you know there's
the rock walking by making him feel
inadequate there's you know he's got a
big dialogue scene he has to memorize
Charlize Theron that Oscar losing him
yeah so this is more like okay I get to
I get to like sneer and and my stunt
doubles gonna have some fun wears a big
coat where that big big ass pretend to
skateboard yeah that's it Neymar shows
up yeah yeah and then like call up if
not his buds than at least people who
will be you know indebted to him for
putting him in a movie yes it seems like
like a good time was had by all
yeah yeah I don't have I don't have as
much animosity towards these movies as I
do some of the fast and furious movies I
think because there's a little bit more
of an understanding in my mind of
exactly what they are yeah and I think
that x3 is actually the best fulfillment
of that promise in that it is the most
over-the-top and the most ridiculous
whereas the first one I think it was
still early enough and close enough to
that like X Games what the type of
person that it didn't go crazy it was
earnest it was earnest yeah exactly but
or was it I don't know like the first
scene of the first movie is him like
stealing a guy's Corvette because he
wants to like ban rap music yes
congressman their senators Corvette
because he hates rap music these many
straps like cameras to it as skate
drives it affords let's watch a few
glorious moments of the xxx franchise
together and a lot more to say yes
thank you two years of waiting for send
s folks if you want to watch some porn
but you're dumb and easily confused do
your best to get off on the xxx
franchise like a porno star
the name is interesting cuz what came
first xxx or Xander cage well his name
was Xander cage to heaven next a -
here's it because some people say this
is an inconsistency because they say
that the program was called the xxx
program but if that's so then why then
why did that I think that he was Xander
cage he had the xxx tattoo Samuel
Jackson was running a covert agent
recruitment program looking for the
extremists of athletes and Xander cage
was so successful that they then named
it the xxx program after him and so
henceforth all agents would be known as
xxx and they had the logo printed on the
foot I was wonderful those government
agencies like but there's a big logo on
the floor like who's like their vinyl
guy they're like I need a big covert
agency logo to be put on the floor I
think they just hire one off Craigslist
then they shoot him in the head
oh yeah that's probably right yeah but
so yeah I think that cuz I'm like oh if
it's why is it called the xxx agency if
Xander cage is the first xxx agent I
think they named it after him so do you
think like the first CIA agent was a guy
named like TRL and he had big CIA neck
like chiaro
CIA okay anyways let's keep going almost
been diesel makes between fats and
Riddick's and the film's Ice Cube makes
between Fridays and are we there yet as
you rock out to a spy trilogy that asks
what if James Bond had twice the
chlamydia his gadgets were designed for
sex criminals and his mission was to
sneak into Ozzfest while wearing
progressively larger codes dude looks
like an ostrich giving birds did you
find that I stepped in ostrich slaying I
typed in because I was like he looks
like an egg coming out of a furry animal
like what but it's kind of bird-like all
right well but it's an ostrich laying an
egg
yeah then we kind of made it our own if
you will we have lots of vaults for that
I hope we still have those do we have
those for that the coat thing here's the
weirdest part of the coat thing in in
researching this movie there's an
interview for x3 and Vin Diesel like the
interviewer asks him about the coats and
he says yeah
you know I was uh I was talking about
the sequel with Mark Zuckerberg and Mark
Zuckerberg tell me you gotta have the
coat such a badass coat so I think that
the first movie it's like he's going
underground in Russia it's cold you need
a big fur coat like a Russian mobster I
guess would wear yes sure but like the
coat became a thing yeah that Marty
loved Mark Zuckerberg according to Vin
Diesel which we were trying to unwind in
the writers room and we figured out
forever
like Vin Diesel had the most liked yes
page on all of Facebook right it's the
biggest page on Facebook so that would
make sense why he would be meeting with
Mark so cool ears sounds like Kermit
slashed George Lucas yeah doing some
interesting things here with them
privacy and I'm gonna be President
someday anyways
let's keep going future less danger
lurks beneath the sexy dance club hooker
mechanic shop or off-the-grid jungle ray
back to the guy who's who is DJing this
is what I love about x3 we don't really
go into it enough but he's got a guy
he's going over it's off the grid if you
scroll back to that Club hooker mechanic
shot that guy he assembles a crew and
it's like Ruby Rose she's a sniper yeah
the Hound from Game of Thrones he's an
explosives expert yeah this guy and he
does it multiple times in the film his
only scale is rocking the park yeah this
guy is party going
this guy appeals to more Asian markets
yeah he is like I don't know
pick an Asian market was some type of
pop star of that it's it's either Japan
Korea or China he's a pop star in one of
those and he his thing as he goes into
the party and he just rocks it everybody
goes nuts when he's in there and you
know you can have a character like that
and triple that gotta have a life of the
party in there somewhere yeah yeah so
props to him character drugs ray from
jungle rivers off-the-grid America will
need a new breed of secret agent and by
secret I mean world famous celebrity
Xander cage this is crazy snowboard
motorbike and won't hesitate to out
themselves if they think it would get
them laid I'm a secret agent
it'd be like being an international so
directly after that when he's very
loudly in a public place saying that she
gets a phone call that's like York has
found out that he's with the exist
secret agent with the NSA she's like oh
like there's probably someone just like
sitting next to them it was like oh he's
a secret agent we should probably call
that dude not the most subtle not very
covert the idea of sending celebrities
undercover in the first place seems a
little dumb like if you gotta get
someone with attitude
you know maybe somebody a little more
off the grid yeah doesn't have like a
wildly popular
I guess pirate radio is known to be like
a subversive yeah I mean maybe that's
why because he's like hate the
government
[Music]
low profile certainly not very low
profile yeah [ __ ] started go
undercover
oh they did that too Vin Diesel is
sander cage a rebel with an obnoxious
attention to detail stockbroker over
here reading the Financial Times on a
Sunday morning the lady that was running
to catch the bus that's a very Jason
that's a very thing like that's like a
Jason Bourne thing yes he's received no
spy training he knows this stuff
immediately which means he's like a
savant ya know he's just like he's like
Rain Man but for only like fake training
scenarios he's been dropped into right
in prepping his whole life for this I
guess he needed attention to detail when
you're shredding some gnarly powder
gnarly powder while also undercutting
the Belgian government yeah yeah the
final thing is like we need to
infiltrate this snowy fortress like
we're gonna drop you out of a plane
right over it or a nearby no like one
peak over yeah you're gonna threaten you
know just sort of shreds yeah it's its
wits because there's like the first one
there's a party like Tony Hawk is
hanging out there it's like even at this
time Tony Hawk was a businessman I don't
think he would be there with like known
government subversive and convicted or
or wanted felon Xander cage yeah
probably not
sadly to say that this era is probably
Tony Hawk to get exactly the transition
he's not gonna risk the IPO I'm being
caught in the in the home aiding and
abetting a known criminal yeah you don't
want to risk that no Matt Hoffman to the
BMX stars in there that wasn't solid
game Tony Hawk Columbus thanks keep
going he rebelled against Authority join
the rebels then rebel against the rebels
to protect the authorities right to be
rebelled against I think just don't get
him confused with Dominic Toretto
because while this tank top trunk also
loves muscle cars
mumble growling citizen in my vocabulary
and surrounding himself with
multi-ethnic world celebrities to
maximize global ticket sales Xander has
an upsetting slack-jawed horny phase
here
close your mouth Finn please no how how
how what he seems to have never had an
interaction with a human I'm sure it's
different when you're being filmed you
know it's not as natural they probably
didn't really get along on set you know
a ton in chemistry and then they just
have to but he's really trying to lap it
up like like a dog at a ball it's just
odd it's just it's disconcerting yeah
it's disturbing because because that's
not like that's not like an Al Gore
Tipper Gore thing where it's like you're
on stage at a convention and you do this
really weird awkward kiss like that was
the best one yeah you're right I'd love
to say had many tries to get that right
and that was the one that they said like
yeah okay that goes in the middle my
guess is his character or you know he's
a bit of a mouth breather it seems like
he doesn't have the the clearest nasal
passages so he's gotta leave room when
he's kissing for oxygen otherwise he'll
suffocate leave like kissing with this
part of the mouth and then this part
open for air it's swimming and coming up
forever it's like a fish there were more
kissing clips but we didn't feel like
suggesting yeah
so yeah let's keep this go watch the
movies it's time to look for someone
with even more attitude more attitude
and bring in the new xxx Darius stone he
doesn't do extreme sports more problems
motion or love the ladies if you need
anything anything you know how about
some fries in a shake but he does hit
people with his elbows a lot
so pause I guess some thoughts overall
on Darius stone first of all that's a
bigger porn name to me than triple exes
Darius stone is the pointiest porn name
even more than Xander cage
yeah he's Darius stone definitely a porn
name just so many unforced errors I
guess Ice Cube just didn't want to skate
didn't want to get on the board or
something but they immediately like I
don't do that stuff but then what do you
do right but I mean it's like we're
talking about the elbow thing here and
we're showing the little bunny hop thing
yeah I I suspect maybe that ice cube may
not be the best like action guy sure
like you know the running is a little
awkward and it's not like Finn's really
skiing down the jungle you know you get
a stunt double for them but like if you
ask but like even in a fight scene like
you know that you know I could do that
like if you were asking me to
convincingly throw a punch on so I
couldn't do it sure I just don't I don't
I lack the coordination and where the
skill to do so so I wonder if perhaps
they're they're sort of cementing over a
little bit they want to make Ice Cube
look like incredible action star and
they're doing what they can't but
perhaps the extreme sports were not
we're not in the cards for him I guess
not I mean the the whole x2 thing was it
was a sad experience for me because that
more attitude scene especially because
it's like we're saying it's like there's
they wrote the studio notes into the
script and it's like we need somebody
well if you don't have Vin Diesel we
need somebody who's more hip-hop more
ruthless more down to the streets more
attitude more attitude I also love how
they they literally the way that they
explain why the diesel is not in the
movie is they're in the Situation Room
and a guy just walks in and says Xander
cage was killed in Bali last night never
in x3 explained like whether that was a
ruse or any I think they briefly
mentioned like he shows up and I think
someone's like aren't you supposed to be
dead sure but it's not not now we go the
end yeah yeah yeah yeah
and the other thing is like what you
need what makes a xxx movie great what
makes it work is that and I maintain
that this is a good premise even though
it's incredibly dumb the way to execute
it is like you send somebody undercover
mm-hmm
who really does have more in common with
the bad guys
a spy who really does have more in
common with the terrorists or with the
rebels then then the agency said break
formula a Point Break formula yeah
you're right you're right they've done
it before but with ice with with cube it
was like he was infiltrating like the
stuffy world of like DC lobbyists and
like and politics and like like these
you know Virginia suburbs and stuff like
that like there's no tension there no
it's not it's not ice ice yeah that that
Xander cage was going to become a member
of building a tiny submarine I forgot
the ending of it yes there was a
submarine equipped with bio with gas
yeah that would that was gonna go
through Prague I want to say sure and
gas everyone yeah it was like no too
extreme I think they couldn't stop the
submarine so they're like this is this
summer it's gonna go all over the world
just like get hit with a rocket
launchers oh no no because only water
neutralize the gas so they had just it's
called a cab got a little bunny hop when
he runs oh it's so cute
on its how I action but chug a Red Bull
for sequences that give the finger to
gravity and logic where cars become
trains bikes become surfboards serving
trays become skateboards skis become
dirt skis and just when it seems like
all hope is lost
I'll grant will emerge to launch the
heroes into glory taking from xxx kids
anything ramp if you put your mind to it
[Music]
what the hell you think you're doing
building around ranch eyes that somehow
overcomes that shot dialogue yeah Kronk
X come on still get crunk with this for
embarrassing needle drops
and parade of stereotypes everything's
alright you did enough work because
enough time has passed that we're
getting nostalgic for the early
two-thousands era of new metal and
nipple tattoos crank that crazy town and
pass the go-gurt I wonder how my new
pets are doing they're all dead yeah oh
jack something very obsessed with this
Neopets of die yeah we debated a lot of
which early 2000s references we should
drop in there biscuit obviously was in
the mix but we just did a biscuit
reference with the fanatic yeah and the
Oscar trailer Powerman 5000 disturbed
what's your favorite terrible early
2000s new metal act fill in your own
below I like that it's like it the most
early 2000s script direction had to be
like fade in a fire concert with
Rammstein it's like a fire via fire
festival but not with them wide and they
sent with Duffy James Bond and they shot
him I lose crowd-surfing
yeah can't do that yeah and then Dan I
found out just before we started rolling
and never heard of Neopets which is the
name but I never was quite sure I never
got into like tamagotchi Neopets any of
that yeah this is just like free to play
pokemon okay I'm the browser had ever
gotten a Pokemon yet okay well yeah the
more you know all right let's get going
bong James Bond hair today gone tomorrow
a leather-clad female double agent every
movie has entered yet the bad guy from
speed - Donny yes and Tony yeah Ruby
Tuesday's Tony Coletti a paycheck your
two favorite PlayStation games you ain't
nothin but a hound dog crashing all the
time
Machat a No Limit album covers 1996 to
2000 and iced cube
mission impossible Oh
I had forgotten when I was watching the
movie right what era and Danny Trejo's
career reworked so when he showed up I
was like oh awesome Danny Trejo was
gonna be like the bad guy in this movie
and then he was in it for like two
minutes you know I'd forgotten we had we
had fully we as a society had yet to
fully realize the many gifts that Danny
Trejo had to offer beyond just
nondescript tough yeah and he just got
roasted bye-bye xxx yeah in his car
right got blown up
yeah well roasted verbally and no and
then actually blown up they just make
fun of him for three minutes and then he
blows up yeah and ignore me ascend for
the great Danny Trejo yeah so that was a
I was I was I was applying current-day
Trejo knowledge to 20 years ago Trejo
appearance and just to show you how much
we've we've grown to appreciate that but
relax does pass his criteria of the is
it the four B's where every Danny Trejo
every movie needs
oh yeah it's like bullets blades babes
saves bombs look up the date rayona and
the four B's I think yeah they're all
great interview footage yeah and man
that guy can that guy's all over Los
Angeles trails tacos trails doughnuts
tacos he's quite the entrepreneur in
addition to being a great character
actor yeah good for you David yeah good
for you dad Rio and he's like a hero he
saved he like helped somebody out of a
car there was like a car wreck and he
like helped get like a kid out of a car
okay a couple years ago which is funny
because they cut to Danny Trejo and he's
there shirtless of course but like seems
like the most humble guy like yeah there
was like a car wreck and like hurt do
that too
Vernor hot dog saved I believe it was
Joaquin Phoenix yeah from an overturned
car on the Sunset Strip he pulled
Joaquin Phoenix out of his overturned
car and Joaquin Phoenix looked up and
was verner Hertzog then disappeared into
the night life comes at you fast yeah
all right let's finish up it's time to
put xxx in more of a hip-hop context so
this is a nice 10% or so then give him a
little more attitude more attitude or go
undercover
where besides a DC area lunch spot Billy
Bob Baker southern baptists Brotherhood
great to meet you Reverend story so
pause that was a poochy reference I hope
you people you people got into we need
to put them in more of a hip-hop context
justified by 10% it is the creation of
poochy scene so one of the many Simpsons
references hidden inside almost every
episode of foster there's a lot yeah men
people like us we can't help ourselves
no it's like a calm it's like our comedy
like codex like it is the it is the
rosetta stone for your people of our age
they're like comedy it's if it's late on
a bedrock of The Simpsons yep
all right let's keep going Ethan stunned
Dominic Toretto
Code Red Nick furious Samuel M Jackson
Anarchy 99 love balloons Willem Dafoe
hashtag no Oscar / Tony hey xxx I mean
next to the third
I mean x-cubed glad I called that guy
triple Plex press X to pay respects
James bong double bro 7 and a guy Vin
Diesel sighs taking stairs five at a
time is Loki the best stunt I've ever
seen yeah that's great shot yeah very
impressive I forgot to tag on the
trailer I think I talked to over at I
apologize that's fine
okay watch the actual trailer okay let
me very quickly address some of people's
comments we should do an honest trailer
for Vin Diesel's entire career pretty
much find me guilty messy can go
undercover in America that's the biggest
soccer star Lionel Messi do you think
that they could send would you recognize
Lionel Messi if he walked in this room I
mean I might not just because I'm not
huge into international soccer however I
think that there are enough people that
would that we have affected yeah there's
enough weirdos and then water crossing
dirt skiing are actual things FYI
yeah yeah you made those up you're just
putting words together are you saying
that they're like I'm not saying
nobody's tried it before but like as far
as a thing where it's like oh welcome to
the is there a dirt ski shop is there a
water cross somebody's got a dealership
selling it right I guess yeah
[Music]
send your Neopets to an EO lodge and you
can forget about them for a month so
this is the crucial stuff you guys
there's a lot many more heads - yeah I
guess they would keep them alive for you
yeah what's the point having them
I know right yeah play with you do
pensacon be good parents monsters
anyways
that's that as far as your contribution
the audience your job is done
your job is done but ours has only just
begun because we will keep doing the
show should conditions permit and next
week will be something even even manlier
than than XXX yeah yeah very much so I
think so yeah so there's a clue and we
hope you enjoyed this week's installment
Vaughn's trailer commentaries we'll see
you then thanks for watching